SECRETARY WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE MINING MINING HERE
ROUGH.
ROUGH HERE WILL PRESENT WILK
HERE ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- BEFORE WE
MOVE INTO A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES.
LET ME SEE IF I CAN GET A
CONSENT CALENDAR ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO WHICH IS THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR.
THAT WOULD BE ITEM D. E. F. G..
ITEM THREE BILLS ARE REFERRALS --
ITEM FOR FLOORING KNOWLEDGE
ANSWER I FOR THROUGH.
I THINK IT'S NINE FOUR THREE
NINE FLOOR KNOWLEDGE MINTS.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR ROTH
MANNER SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROSS ROSS I WILL.
WILK AYE ATKINS ATKINS AYE THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES -- THEY HAD --
THE CONSENT AGENDA PASSES.
FIVE ZERO AND LET ME INVITE --
FOLKS FORWARD HELLO SUPER MY
SUPERVISOR -- MISTER FLETCHER.
MEGAN MCGINNIS AND DEANDRE A
FREMONT -- LET'S SEE WE'VE GOT
TO FOR THE ERROR.
ACTUALLY WILL START WITH MISTER
FLETCHER I'M SORRY THESE ARE
THREE DIFFERENT BOARDS PLEASE
FORGIVE ME.
MISTER FLETCHER SUPERVISOR COME
ON FORWARD THIS IS FOR THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON LET ME INVITE YOU
TO MAKE OPENING COMMENTS
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE
PRESENT. TO SUPPORT YOU THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
OF YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER ATKINS AND AND
OUR OUR VICE CHAIR -- SENATOR
BATES IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
WITH YOU -- I ALSO WANT -- TO
GIVE A SPECIAL THANKS -- TO TO
MY WIFE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
DODD WHO IS WHO IS HERE AS WELL
FOR FOR A CONFIRMATION HEARING --
I APPRECIATE THE TIME OF HE
SENATE I REALLY VIEW -- THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS -- IS THE
BEGINNING OF AN ENGAGEMENT ON
ISSUES RELATED. TO YOUR
RESOURCES BOARD AND NOT THE END --
I THINK THAT THE ONGOING
ENGAGEMENT AND DIALOGUE IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- AND IF SUCCESSFUL
IN THE CONFIRMATION PROCESS AND
VERY COMMITTED.
ON THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS IS
PERSONALLY IMPORTANT TO ME AND
MY SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICT IN SAN
DIEGO.
A CHILD BORN IN ONE PART OF MY
DISTRICT IN A CHILD BORN IN THE
OTHER PART OF MY DISTRICT
THERE'S A TEN YEAR DISPARITY IN
LIFE EXPECTANCY.
TODAY IN SAN DIEGO IN CALIFORNIA
AND ONE SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICT.
A CHILD BORN IN IN IN ONE PART
IS EIGHT TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE ASTHMA THAN A CHILD BORN IN
THE OTHER PART.
I BELIEVE THAT SOME MORE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH OUR VALUES AND
BELIEFS.
AND SO OUR COMMITMENT TO HAVING
CLEAN AIR OUR COMMITMENT TO
LOWER IN OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TO TACKLE THE USES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
ARE VITALLY IMPORTANT AND THE
AUTHORITY THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS GIVEN THE CARB -- HAS TO BE
PROPERLY EXECUTED IMPLEMENTED
WITH THE PROPER ENGAGEMENT AND
THE MOST IMPORTANT COUNT
ABILITIES.
ARE SO THAT WE CAN MEET OUR OUR
OUR CO GOALS OF LOWERING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND SO I'M
VERY COMMUNITIES ISSUES AS I'VE
ONLY BEEN TO A HANDFUL OF
MEETINGS HAS BEEN APPOINTED --
BUT AM I AM AND WORKING HARD TO
GET UP TO SPEED AND I APPRECIATE
THE SENATE'S CONSIDERATION OF MY
APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU SUPERVISOR FLETCHER --
LET ME START WITH US SENATOR
ROSS.
THANK YOU MANAGER
CONGRATULATIONS SUPERVISOR THANK
YOU GENERAL THIS MAY BE A A
LITTLE.
SOON TO BE ASKING YOU THIS
QUESTION.
THE CHIU JUST ESSENTIALLY
STARTED WITH A FEW MEETINGS
UNDER YOUR BELT BUT ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IS WHETHER WE TO A VERY
GOOD JOB OF SETTING GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND METRICS AND
MEASURING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
PROGRAMS AND IN PARTICULAR -- AT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD SEE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
PROGRAMS.
OF THE WE HAVE IN PLACE SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS HOW SHOULD
WE BE MEASURING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
IN A TWO PARTER SHOULD THERE BE
A PERIODIC RE EVALUATION OF
PROGRAMS.
GENERAL I WOULD SAY THE ONE OF
THE FEW MEETINGS I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF ATTENDING WE RECEIVE
THE S. B. ONE FIFTY REPORT --
WHICH IS A LEGISLATIVELY
REQUIRED REPORT FOR CARD TO
ASSESS -- ITS TRAJECTORY IN
SUCCESS IN IN MEETING THE SB
THIRTY TWO GOALS FOR A 40%
REDUCTION BELOW NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS.
BY TWENTY THIRTY AND REALITIES
WERE NOT ON TRACK TO MEET OUR
GOALS -- WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WELL
I'M SORRY WE ARE NOT ON TRACK --
TO MEET OUR GOALS AND IN FACT ON
THE SITUATION IS GTTING WORSE.
INSTEAD OF BETTER AND THAT'S
THAT'S PRIMARILY IN LARGE PART
DUE. TO THE EVER INCREASING
NUMBER OF VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
BUT I DO THINK IN THE LA -- HOW
TO ADD A PRETTY EXHAUSTIVE
REPORT ON THIS AND AND DECEMBER --
THAT WE HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB
TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT IN PLACE ARE EFFECTIVE.
ARE COST EFFECTIVE ARE ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING MEASURABLE GOALS AND
IF THEY'RE NOT THEN WE NEED TO
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
SAY THIS PROGRAM WAS PUT IN
PLACE WE DON'T THINK THAT IT'S
WORKING.
HI THIS IS WHERE WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE THERE'S THERE'S
POTENTIAL FOR CHANGE AND SO.
I THINK THAT THE THE NATURE OF A
OF A PROGRAM BY ITSELF HAS NO
PURPOSE IT'S ONLY IN ITS
EFFECTIVENESS -- TO LOWER
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS LOWER
AIR POLLUTION AND SO.
I THINK EVERY PROGRAM MUST BE
CONSTANTLY MONITORED AND%
EVALUATED -- AND IF THERE'S ONE
THAT'S WORKING EXPERT JUST FOR
THE PROGRAM'S WORKING DOESN'T
MEAN THAT'S THE BEST ALLOCATION
RESOURCES THERE COULD BE ANOTHER
ONE THAT'S WORKING BETTER WE
SHOULD DO MORE OF THAT -- ONE
BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF MEDIAN
THAT THE LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED
GOALS WE'RE GONNA.
HAVE TO BE INCREDIBLY EFFICIENT
AND INCREDIBLY ACCOUNTABLE -- TO
ACHIEVE THE ENDS THAT THAT WE
SICK.
WELL I HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH YOU
AND THE LA -- SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO WATCHING YOU.
WORK AND PERFORM ONE SURE -- YOU
ARE CONFIRMED AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MANAGER.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR WELL
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T GET A
CHANCE TO TEND TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION -- AS SOMEBODY WHO
BELIEVES IN CLIMATE CHANGE I
THINK THEY'RE WORTHY GOALS ONE
OF MY FRUSTRATIONS AND I'M
INTEREST IN YOUR PERSPECTIVE SO
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE
NOW YOU CAN HAVE THIS ROLE.
IS -- HOW COLLABORATIVE WE ALL
BE BETWEEN THAT THE AGENCY AND
IN THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE WE'VE
SEATED A LOT OF POWER AND
AUTHORITY? TO THE BOARD AND SO
I'M JUST I'M JUST CURIOUS.
ARE YOU SEE THOSE DYNAMICS
WORKING WELL HAVING HAVING SAT
IN A LEGISLATIVE BODY NOT IN THE
SENATE -- IN IN THE LOWER HOUSE --
IN IN THE ASSEMBLY THANKS FOR
SAYING NO.
I KNOW WHICH HOUSE AMEND -- YOU
GET SHOT YOUR DIGITAL YOU GET
ALL THIS IS.
THE I WOULD JUST SAY HE'S GOING
TO GET IN TROUBLE COLLEAGUES BE
CAREFUL THE I DON'T I DON'T HAVE.
BUT THE HAVING HAVING SAT THERE
I MEAN LEGISLATIVE BODIES BY
THEIR VERY NATURE VERY
RESPONSIVE TO THE PUBLIC --
BECAUSE THAT IS THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY YOUR EXISTENCE.
AND WHEN LEGISLATIVE BODIES SET
A GOAL AND GREATER REGULATORY
ENTITY TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL THAT
REGULATORY ENTITY BY ITS NATURE
IS NOT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT IT
DERIVES ITS POWER FROM FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND AND I THINK IT'S VITALLY
IMPORTANT THAT REGULATORY
ENTITIES.
REALLY UNDERSTAND DEEPLY THAT
THAT THEY THEY HAVE NO POWER
OTHER THAN THAT GRANTED TO THEM
BY THE LEGISLATURE -- AND SO
THAT THE CONSTANT IN GAUGE MEN
AND INTERACTION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS TO RESPOND INCREASE TO
RESPOND TO SUGGESTIONS -- I
THINK IS A VITAL PART AND I
THINK I THINK INCREASING THAT
THAT BOND IN THAT RELATIONSHIP.
OCT CAN CAN A SERVE TO TO ENSURE
THE TRUST OF THE THE ENTITY THAT
CREATED IT.
BUT ALSO TO TO GENERAL'S POINT.
CAN CONSERVE TO TO TO BUILD SOME
TRUST SO THAT IF IF IF THERE BE
WERE TO COME BACK AND SAY THIS
PROGRAM WAS CREATED WITH THE
BEST OF INTENTIONS BUT PERHAPS
IT SHOULD CHANGE.
THEN WE HAVE THAT COULD WELL IN
THAT TRUST GO FORWARD -- AND I
ALSO THINK I ALSO THINK AND THIS
IS SOMETHING.
I THINK FOR A LOT OF AGENCIES
KIND OF FOREIGN -- BUT THE AB
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM I BELIEVE
IS A VERY GOOD PROGRAM.
I THINK THAT WAS GOOD
LEGISLATION I THINK THAT IT IS
DRIVING IN THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH
THE AIR DISTRICTS -- IN IN THE
IN THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES AND TO REALLY WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMUNITY --
AND TO HEAR ABOUT CONCERNS IN A
PRIORITIZE FUNDING. FOR PROGRAMS
IN COMMUNITIES MOST MPACTED AND
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S A A
MINDSET SHIFT THAT IS A POSITIVE.
ONE A MAN IF A MEMBER OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD I WILL BE
RESPONSIVE PERSON HAVING.
SAT IN THAT SEAT IN ENSURING
THAT THE PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU
HAVE GREAT THANK YOU.
ABOUT.
SO ONE OF THE QUESTION I HAVE
I'M INTERESTED TO KNOW WHERE YOU
KIND OF THINK THE SWEET SPOT IS
SO I'M I'VE GOT WORKING CLASS
DISTRICT.
AND I HAVE A TINY COMMUTERS AND
THEY DON'T WANT TO COMMUTE UT
THEIR FORCES COMMITTEES I GOTTA
FIFTY THOUSAND COME OUT CENTER
CREE BALLY HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
DAY COMING OUT OF ANIL FAMILY
ABOUT EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND COME
OUT THE VICTOR VALLEY.
SO WHAT'S WHAT'S THE BOUNCE
BETWEEN.
ECONOMIC YOU KNOW REGULATIONS
AND AND ECONOMIC ITALITY WHERE
TO HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU BALANCE THAT WATER I DON'T
THINK THE TWO ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE YOU KNOW WE WE CREATED
MORE JOBS.
IN THE SOLAR INDUSTRY -- YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR THAN THAN AN
OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY --
AND SO I DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE TO THEIR THEIR IS
INHERENTLY AT TIMES THE ROB --
BETWEEN THE TWO BUT I THINK I
THINK PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES
TO TRANSPORTATION -- WHEN YOU
REALLY ANALYZE THE CONCEPT OF OF
INDUCED DEMAND AND YOU LOOK AT
EXAMPLES OF OF HOW DO YOU
ACTUALLY LOWER CONGESTION --
WHICH HAS THE BENEFIT OF HELPING
FOLKS.
WHO ARE WANT TO SPEND MORE TIME
WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND HAS THE
BENEFIT OF OF LOWER IN OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS ARE
CARBON EMISSIONS?
OUR AIR QUALITY STANDARDS I'M
REALLY TRYING TO REALIGN SOME OF
THAT THINKING -- BEHIND A
GREATER INVESTMENT IN TRANSIT
AND I I THINK THAT THAT'S VITAL
I DON'T BELIEVE WE CAN WE CAN
BUILD FREEWAYS TO TO GET HERSELF
OUT OF THIS PROBLEM.
A AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO A
REAL LINE AND IN ONE OF THE MOST
TROUBLING ASPECTS OF A RECENT
REPORT.
WAS IN LAST TEN YEARS WE REALLY
HAVEN'T SIGNIFICANTLY ALTER THE
STRUCTURE OF OUR TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING -- AND SO WE WONDER WHY
THE EMPTIES AND CONGESTION KEEP
GOING UP AND SO I THIK THAT'S
NOW THAT THAT'S NOT INHERENTLY A
ROLL OF CARB -- BUT WE ARE
DEPENDENT UPON OUR NPOS OUGHT TO
MEET THE SB THREE SEVEN FIVE
GOALS -- AND A LOT OF THEM ARE
NOT IN AND SO I THINK WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH THIS ISSUE OF
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING --
AND WE HAVE THESE KIND OF
COMPETING IN CONFLICTING GOALS.
AND SO ONE THING WHEN YOU
MENTION COLLABORATION THAT I
THINK IS VITAL.
AS AN ENTITY LIKE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD -- THE CTC HI
THE ENERGY COMMISSION HI YOU
KNOW THESE ENTITIES HAVE TO
BETTER START ALIGNING THEMSELVES --
AND WORK WORKING WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ULTIMATELY HAVE
THE LAND USE AUTHORITY -- TO TRY
AND GET US IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
STRATEGIC SENSE SO WE CAN WE CAN
ACHIEVE THE GOALS WE HAVE ON
CLIMATE AND AIR QUALITY.
OF LOSS OF IN MIND FOR THE THE
IMPACT ON FAMILIES RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR.
AND CHAIR [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
SUPERVISOR FLETCHER
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT JOB AND
YOU'VE TAKEN ON ANOTHER BIG WIN --
TO BE TE ASSIGNEE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR -- COMMISSION ON YOUR
RESPONSES SO FAR OR CERTAINLY
TOTALLY RIGHT IN LINE WITH HOW I
VIEW.
BY YOUR ROLE AND I'M VERY VERY
PLEASED AND I THINK WE SHARE
THAT IN OUR OFFICE DISCUSSION.
THAT YOU HAVE SUCH RESPECT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE WAS THE ROLE IN
TERMS OF THE REGULATORY
STRUCTURE THAT IS APPROVED HERE
BUT GOES OVER TO THEM AND YOU
KNOW HOW IT'S HOW IT'S ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED.
CAN HAVING THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES ARE QUANTIFIED AND
REVIEWED ON WITH SAND ON SENATOR
ROSS QUESTION WAS ONE OF MINE
AND YOU'VE ANSWERED THAT ARE.
REALLY IN MORE DEPTH THAN WE
WOULD HAVE ANTICIPATED SO YOU
HAVE A GREAT GRASP AND HAVEN'T
BEEN THERE THAT LONG SO I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO BE REALLY GOOD.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION REGARDING
CAP AND TRADE AND WE DID TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE IT WAS SIGNED NOT
RECEIVED AS WELL -- INITIALLY IN
TERMS OF WHERE IT WAS GOING
WITHOUT -- YOUR DISCUSSION
REGARDING THE BALANCE OF CAP AND
TRADE AS COMPARED TO REGULATIONS
I THOUGHT WAS VERY GOOD.
IN TERMS OF CAP AND TRADE BEING
A MORE PREFERRED METHOD YOU
SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT WITH
THE FIRE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
IN TERMS OF THE EDUCATION.
RIGHT OUT SO YOU KNOW WE NEED IN
TERMS OF THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
WELL IN THIS THIS THIS BODY AT A
AT A ROBUST DEBATE -- I SURE TO
SENATOR BATES AND AND ARMENIAN I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A A SEGMENT OF
OF OLKS WHO WHO DON'T LIKE CAP
AND TRADE -- AND THERE'S A
SECOND FOLKS -- ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE SPECTRUM HOSPITAL I
CAPTURED -- FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS THAT HAPPENED HAPPENED
TO ALIGN -- BUT YOU KNOW THIS
BODY CAME UP WITH THAT AND I I
BELIEVE THE CAP AND TRADE IS A
PIECE.
OF THE TOTALITY OF HOW WE
ACHIEVE OUR GOALS I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT BE A CAP AND TRADE
ALONE.
A WE CAN GET WHERE WHERE WE NEED
TO BE -- BUT THE NOTION THAT
THAT WE CAN CAN SET TARGETS FOR
THE THE ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ENTITIES THAT PRODUCE
ABOUT 85% OF OF THE EMISSIONS --
AND AND THROUGH -- A COMBINATION
OF ALLOWANCES A AND A MARKET
BASED SYSTEM -- AND THEN THROUGH
THE POTENTIAL FOR OFFSETS --
WHICH ARE TWO DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF OF THE CAP AND
TRADE SYSTEM.
ON THAT WE CAN GET ON THE
TRAJECTORY WE HAD OUR OUR TWENTY
THIRTY GOALS IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY.
I TO INDUSTRY SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE. TO BE AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE WHICH WHICH IS ALSO ALSO
IMPORTANT TO US -- I THINK AS WE
MONITORING WE TRACK THAT
CAPTURED PROGRAM GOING FORWARD
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS WE HAVE
TO BE MINDFUL OF ONE IS THAT
WHAT IS THE IMPACT.
BOTH PLACE.
WHAT IS THE IMPACT ON CARBON
EMISSIONS AND WHAT IS THE IMPACT
ON THE ECONOMY -- THERE'S BEEN
SOME CRITICISM -- THAT FOR SOME
OF THE INDUSTRY'S WERE WE FEAR --
LEAKAGE OR A POTENTIAL MOVING TO
THE FREE ALLOWANCES ARE PERHAPS
TOO GENEROUS -- AND THAT'S AN
ISSUE AGAIN FINDING THAT BALANCE
THAT YOU HAVE TO STRIKE.
ON THERE'S ALSO BEEN CONCERNED --
EXPRESS NEARLY A REPORT AND
OTHERS OF THE POTENTIAL OF
BANKING IN -- ALLOWANCES AT A
POINT WHERE THEY'RE AT A LOWER
PRICE POINT TO POTENTIALLY CASH
THEM IN AND OUT YEARS WHERE IT
WOULD APPEAR THAT WERE MEETING
GOALS WERE NOT ACTUALLY MEETING --
AND THAT AGAIN JUST COMES BACK --
TO APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
APPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATION ON
AND ENSURING THAT THAT WE'RE
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING -- AND MINDFUL SO THAT
WE CAN WE CAN ACHIEVE BOTH OF
THOSE GOALS.
WELL IT'S VERY APPARENT THAT
YOU'RE WELL PREPARED FOR THE
FINE LINE MEANT THAT YOU'RE
TAKING ON SO WE SHE WELL
ANSWERED SO I'M IN LA A REPORT
IN DECEMBER AND THERE'S LIKE
FIVE OF THEM SO I DID A MALL
THERE'S LIKE DECEMBER OF EVERY
YEAR THEY ASSUME SO.
CONGRATULATIONS AND I'LL BE
PREPARED TO SUPPORT YOU AND WE
GET TO THE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR.
I DON'T KNOW IT'S GETTING
TOUGHER AND SENATOR MINING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND WELCOME HOME
WELCOME BACK TO TO THE BUILDING
AND WE HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING
TOGETHER IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
SEE OUR FORMER SPEAKER JOHN
PEDIS IS HERE.
WELCOME WELCOME BACK MISTER
SPEAKER TO YOU AS WELL.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT APPRECIATED OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK LEAVE.
INTERFACE TO THE COUPLE MEETING
SAYS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
APPOINTED BY OUR PRO TEM TO CSUS
REPRESENT THE SENATE ON CARBS SO
I AM LOOKING FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOU THERE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YEAR.
KIND OF SETTING THE STAGE IN
RESPONSE TO SENATOR.
WILKES QUESTION OF THE
APPROPRIATE RELATIONSHIP OF
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN CARBON IN
THE LEGISLATURE WHERE THERE'S
SOME TENSION AND MAYBE HEALTHY
TENSION BUT ALSO IMPORTANCE OF
THE BUILDING COLLABORATION --
YOU DEMONSTRATED THREE WORKING
KNOWLEDGE OF THE ISSUES WERE
GRAPPLING WITH AND JUST POSE ONE
QUESTION TO LET YOU.
ON RESPOND TO AN WHEN WE SPOKE
YOU YOU ADDRESS A LITTLE BUT
WE'RE MAKING.
PROGRESS ON A RENEWABLE ENERGY
PORTFOLIO WERE FALLING BEHIND ON
OUR VEHICLE -- A MISSION
CHALLENGES AND YOU ALLUDED TO
TRANSIT BUT MAYBE JUST SPEND A
LITTLE MORE TIME HAD A WEE --
HAD WE RECTIFY.
OUR OUR OUR LACK OF PROGRESS IF
YOU WILL ON VEHICLE EMISSIONS
WELL IN THAT THAT IS THAT IS THE
REAL CHALLENGE CENTER IS THAT IS
THAT WE HAVE -- YOU KNOW WERE
INTRODUCTORY TO DO AS MUCH ON ON
THE ENERGY SECTORS AS POSSIBLE --
TO CAP AND TRADE WERE WORKING ON
YOUR STATIONARY SOURCES IN HERE
YOUR THIRTY FIVE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISCS ARE DOING DOING
WHAT THEY CAN AS WELL --
INCIDENT COMES UNDER THE ANTIS
IN.
YOU KNOW I I THINK IS A REGION
IN THIS IS NOT.
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED -- AS A
AS A AS AN ENTITY CARB.
THE CARD HAS NO LAND USE OR
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND SO
THIS IS WHERE THERE REALLY HAS
TO BE THAT COLLABORATION --
BETWEEN -- OUR OUR REGIONAL
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS ARE NPOS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN BETWEEN OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SO THAT WE CAN TRY AND ALIGN AS
BEST WE CAN THAT THE DUAL
CHALLENGES OF YOU KNOW IF WE
HAVE TO BUILD MORE HOUSING WHICH
I I BELIEVE MOST OF US BELIEVE
WE DO -- AND WE HAVE TO ALSO NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
AND THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A A
RETHINKING OF OF OF OUR
PRIORITIES A AND R. ALIGNMENT
AND THE AND THE CHALLENGES IN
FRONT OF US -- AND THAT IS GOING
TO REALLY GET DOWN TO THE TO THE
CRUX OF OF THAT COLLABORATIVE
ISSUE -- BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
KNOW WE HAD A AN ISSUE.
SAN DIEGO JUST YESTERDAY WHERE
ARE -- MPO STAND ACT I HAD A
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN
THAT THE COURTS RULED WAS
INCONSISTENT WITH SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE GOALS.
AND THEY CAME OUT AND REVISE
THAT PLAN AND PUTTING IT FORWARD
TO INVESTIGATE SECONDLY MORE IN
TRANSIT MOVING FORWARD -- BUT
THAT'S IT'S A IT'S A TENSION IN
THE IT'S A ROB AND AND THAT IS
BY THINK LAYING OUT THROUGHOUT
ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS AS WE TRY
AND TRYING TO LINE THESE THINGS.
AND SO AT THE END OF THE DAY
CARP IS GOING TO HAVE TO
CONFRONT THE REALITIES OF OF THE
CARS THAT ARE PUT ON THE ROAD.
BY LOCAL LAND USE DECISIONS UP
PERHAPS WITH WITH GREATER
COLLABORATION AT A RECENT CAR
MEETING -- WE SPENT A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME ON A
ON A FREIGHTER WAREHOUSE
HANDBOOK A AS YOU SEE AN ECONOMY
THIS CHANGING FROM MORE BRICK
AND MORTAR RETAIL -- TO MORE
DELIVERY BUT FOLKS WANT THAT
DELIVERY NOW PEOPLE DON'T WANT
SOMETHING SHIPPED HIM IN THREE
DAYS THEY WANTED TOMORROW WELL
THAT'S PUSHING WAREHOUSES AND
OTHER AREAS AND WE'RE TRYING TO
TALK THINK ABOUT.
HOW WE CAN MAKE SUGGESTIONS OR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS -- ELECTRIC VEHICLES HAVE
A PROMISE.
OF OF LOWERING OBVIOUSLY THERE
THERE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AS
LONG AS THE ENERGY THAT CHARGES
THEM AS IS CLEAN -- BUT IN SAN
DIEGO WE HAVE THREE MILLION
REGISTERED VEHICLES.
WE HAVE THIRTY THOUSAND ELECTRIC
CARS.
SO WE COULD HAVE A TEN FOLD
INCREASE AND STILL BE UNDER 10%
OF THE TOTAL ON THERE SOME GREAT
SOCIETAL EQUITY ISSUES.
AROUND ELECTRIC CARS AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES GET TALKED ABOUT A LOT
AND AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES HAVE
SOME POTENTIAL ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE ZERO EMISSION BUT A A
STUDY ON THE UC DAVIS SO THAT
AUTONOMOUS CARS.
INCREASE USAGE BY 80% BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY DRIVE
IT AND PARK IT MOVE IT YOU USE
IT MORE -- AND SO I THINK THOSE
ARE THINGS WE HAVE TO BE REALLY
MINDFUL OF AN AND I'LL JUST SAY
ONE THING.
ON THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
THAT IS SO VITALLY IMPORANT.
IS THE FEDERAL ROLL BACKS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED AND THESE ARE
GONNA HAVE DEVASTATING
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HEY WE AS A STATE
ADOPTED.
WE ARE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
FOR THE FUEL BECAUSE IN THE CAR
BUT WE ADOPTED EMISSION
STANDARDS FOR THE ACTUAL
OPERATION OF THE VEHICLE -- AND
THE MILES PER GALLON.
OUR EMISSIONS STANDARDS THE
ABILITY TO DO THOSE WAS A WAIVER.
UNDER SECTION ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
THE CLEAN AIR ACT.
AND OTHER STATES HAVE ADOPTED
ARE STANDARD TO THE POINT WHERE
WE'RE NEARING 40% OF THE CARS IN
THE COUNTRY OR ON OUR STANDARD.
AND WE WORKED OUT WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT WOULD BECOME
THE FEDERAL STANDARD MOVING
FORWARD -- AND THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
ROLLING OUT BACK NOW THE AUTO
INDUSTRY AS A SUPPORT ROLE IN
THE BACK -- CERTAINLY THE STATES
THAT HAVE A DON'T SUPPORT ROLE
IN THAT BACK.
IN THE IMPACT OF THE ROLL BACK
IRONICALLY WOULD LOWER MILES PER
GALLON WHICH WOULD INCREASE THE
COST TO CONSUMERS THEY WOULD
HAVE TO PUT MORE GAS IN THERE
LESS EFFICIENT CARS TO GONNA
MAKE TAXPAYERS PAY MORE -- BUT
IT ALSO WOULD PUT FIFTEEN
MILLION METRIC TONS OF CARBON
BACK HERE IT'S TWO POINT NINE
CARS AND SO.
FIGHTING THOSE AND EFFORTS LIKE
SB ONE I THINK OR OF VITAL PART
OF HAVING ANY CHANCE. TO ACHIEVE
THAT THE GOALS HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED IN AS YOU POINT OUT ITS
MULTI FACTORIAL -- PROXIMITY OF
FOUR PEOPLE WORK BY WHERE THEY
HAVE TO DRIVE FOR WORK -- OUR
HABITS OF PERSONAL FREEDOM AND
MOBILITY IN OUR OWN CARS
CHARGING STATIONS WE TALKED
ABOUT.
I GREW UP IN LOS ANGELES.
WHERE THE AIR QUALITY WAS WORSE
THAN IT IS TODAY WITH MORE
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD?
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF CLEAN AIR
STANDARDS CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
GETTING RID OF LEADED GAS ALL OF
THAT WAS GOVERNMENT.
PUBLIC HEALTH INITIATIVES NOT
INDUSTRY VOLUNTEERISM AND SO WE
DO HAVE.
TO KEEP THAT IN MIND IN WE DO
HAVE TO BE VIGILANT AS THE
FEDERAL LAWSUIT TO PLAN OUT OF
IT -- MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK YOU -- FORMER COLLEAGUE
CURRENT CALLING ON KARMA I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
COLLABORATION AND LOOK FOR JUST
SUPPORTING YOUR NOMINATION THANK
YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU A SENATOR MINING AND I
IT'S CLEAR YOU CAME PREPARED TO
TALK POLICY -- I WILL HAVE
PROBABLY A COUPLE OF CLOSING
COMMENTS -- AFTER WE HAVE
SPEAKERS I DON'T I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB OF ASKING QUESTIONS AND
YOU'VE CERTAINLY AS AGAIN I SAID
COME PREPARED.
TO REALLY GET INTO THE DETAILS
OF THE JOB IT'S CLEAR THAT HE
WHO ARE MORE THAN READY -- IS TO
TAKE THIS ON WITH THAT I WANT TO
AND SEE WHO IS HERE IN SUPPORT.
AND IT RECOGNIZING THE THE
SPEAKER EMERITUS AND THE CHAIR
OF OUR APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE TO LET GO
FIRST -- MY SPEAKER BUT AGAIN I
WILL RECOGNIZE THE CHAIR THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FIRST
IF THAT'S OKAY SO SHE CAN GET
BACK TO WORK DID YOU COME TO
SPEAK.
LET THE RECORD REFLECT.
SPEAKER EMERITUS -- IF IT WITH
THE COURTESY -- I WILL LET YOU I
JUST WANNA COME LET MY SUPPORT
FOR CONFIRMATION.
I THINK -- THE CANDIDATE IS
DEMONSTRATEDHIS ABSOLUTE FOCUS
AS HE ALWAYS HAS.
THANK YOU STEVE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE BAKER WITH CERTAINLY IN
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
REPRESENTS THE ENGINEERS THAT
WORK AT THE BORDERS A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THEM THERE.
IT WAS THE ENGINEERS AND SENATOR
ROSS DISTRICT THAT DISCOVERED
THE VW CHEATING SCANDAL THAT
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH -- THEY
WORK ON A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS
WITH THEY THINK THAT.
A MISTER FLETCHER'S PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCE WORKING HERE AS WELL
AS ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
MAKE HIM WILL SERVE TO BE A
LEADER CARBON LOOK FOR TO HAVE
IN THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WELCOME.
MANAGER MEMBERS PAT RIGHT WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS THE SCIENTISTS WHO
WORK AT CARP.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE NOMINATION
ENCOURAGES -- RATIFICATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DAN CHAU WITH TESLA
HAPPY TO SUPPORT SUPERVISOR --
FLEXES NOMINATION MIGHT.
FIRST EXPOSURE -- TO MISTER
FLETCHER WAS WHEN HE WAS THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- AND THEN
REPUBLICAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WHO TOOK GREAT INTEREST IN SOLAR
ENERGY YOU -- BEFORE A TEST OF
THE ACQUISITION OF SOLAR CITY --
AND IT WAS GREAT TO BE ABLE TO
TELL OUR STORY OF HOW TO
INCREASE PENETRATION OF OF SOLAR --
SPECIALLY TO THOSE WHO COULD NOT
AFFORD THE UP FRONT COSTS -- AND
HIS -- GREAT ATTENTION AND
RESONATED WITH HIM I RECALL --
MORE RECENTLY WITH HIS --
LEADERSHIP ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- HOW DEVELOPING
STRATEGIES TO INCREASE
ELECTRIFICATION TRANSFORMATIONAL
EDUCATION VIA?
THE TV ROAD MAP -- THAT HE'S
TAKING A LEADERSHIP ROLE ON
SEWER RIVER -- VERY EXCITED TO
SEE THAT AND THE FORTY CONTINUE
TO WORKING WITH HIM -- IN HIS
DISTRICT OF ALSO ON THEIR WISHES
PORTS OF FULLY SUPPORTED
NOMINATION THANK.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- I WILL JUST CONCLUDE BY.
BY SAYING THIS IS A REGIONAL
APPOINTMENT AND I APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S OUR RECOGNITION OF
THE TALENT OF BOTH THE SENATOR
BATES AND I REPRESENT.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY -- NORTHERN
PORTIONS SOUTHERN PORTION AND I
WOULD JUST SAY HOW WONDERFUL IT
IS TO SEE A LOT OF THINGS
ALIGNED.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD PLAYS?
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT -- THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BETWEEN
THE ENERGY COMMISSION THAT
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SENATOR
KEY H
THAT WE ALSO HAVE ON SENDEK YOU
MENTIONED ARE IN PO -- ARE HOT
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT SYSTEM IS
LED BY A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
GEORGIA GOMEZ.
BETWEEN CHRIS AND GEORGETTE AND
ALSO DIANNE TECH LORIAN ON THE
BOARD.
I REALLY FEEL LIKE OUR REGION IS
WELL SERVED -- IN REGARDS TO ALL
OF THOSE ISSUES THAT YOU LAID
OUT.
AND SO -- IT'S REALLY AN HONOR.
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOU TODAY
BECAUSE THIS REALLY IS AN
ALIGNMENT OF OF TRYING TO WORK
ON THESE ISSUES VERY SERIOUSLY
AND DIRECTLY.
ON THE GROUND AND SO I KNOW IT
WILL BE A GOOD -- PARTNERSHIP --
SENATOR ROTH OF MADE THE MOTION
I THINK AND WITH THAT OUR MEN OF
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
IT'S ALL I MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH.
ROUGH I WILL WILK AYE ATKINS HI.
CONGRATULATIONS SUPERVISORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
AS WE TRANSITION LET ME WELCOME
FORWARD -- MEGAN MCGINNIS WHO I
IS AN APPOINTED MEMER OF THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
APPEAL BOARD.
TIME IS WE GET US WELCOME THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY -- I'LL
INVITE YOU ALSO.
TO MAKE OPENING COMMENTS
RECOGNIZE ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO THAT IS HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
YOU -- PEOPLE LIKE TO DO THAT --
AND THEN WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO
OUR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM
FROM THE RULES COMMITTEE WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME --
MY HUSBAND AND FAMILY COULDN'T
BE HERE TODAY BUT I THINK HE'S
TUNING AND SO.
YOU CAN'T SEE HIM BUT HE CAN SEE
YOU HELLO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM ATKINS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR TAKING THE TIME AND
CONSIDERATION IN REVIEWING MY
APPOINTMENT.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE BEFORE
YOU TODAY AND IT'S BEEN A
PRIVILEGE FOR ME TO SERVE THE
LAST NINE MONTHS ON THE ABC
APPEALS BOARD.
I'M GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR BROWN.
FOR HIS CONFIDENCE IN MY ABILITY
TO CONTRIBUTE ON THIS BOARD INTO
GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR PROVIDING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE.
SINCE MY FIRST BOARD MEETING IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN I'VE
BEEN COMMITTED TO LEARNING ABOUT
THE APPEALS PROCESS AND I'M
SORRY THANK YOU.
A AND UP HOLDING THE PRINCIPLES
OF FAIRNESS AND IMPARTIALITY.
WITH EACH DECISION WE REVIEW.
ENSURING THAT ALL LICENSEES
RECEIVED TO PROCESS.
WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT SERVING
ON THE ABC APPEALS BOARD IS THE
ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA?
NOT ONLY LICENSE HOLDERS WHO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXERCISE
THEIR DUE PROCESS RIGHTS.
BUT THE PATRONS OF THOSE
ESTABLISHMENTS THAT HOLD A
LICENSE AND THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
MY PREVIOUS EXPERIENCES IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AS AN
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER.
WHICH TAUGHT ME SKILLS THAT ARE
INVALUABLE TO MY ROLE ON THE
BOARD FOR INSTANCE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION. TO DETAILS WHILE
KEEPING THE BIG PICTURE IN MIND.
TREATING EACH STORY IS UNIQUE IN
USING MY BEST JUDGMENT KNOWING
MY CHOICES HAVE THE POWER TO
IMPACT PEOPLE'S LIVES.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT THE EXPERIENCE
AND SKILLS THAT I BRING.
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO KEEP AN
OPEN MIND MAKE DIFFICULT YET
FAIR DECISIONS AND TREAT EACH
CASE IS UNIQUE IS SOMETHING THAT
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THE MISSION
AND FUTURE SUCCESS OF THIS BOARD.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE FOR ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MONNING I THINK I'LL START ON
YOUR SIDE THIS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
IN A MISS MCGINNIS
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO DATE --
IN PRIOR SERVICE TO TO THE STATE.
SO.
I WAS ENCOURAGED BY OUR
CONVERSATIONS -- I THINK WE
SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT THE MINOR DE QUAIS
PROGRAM AND PPEALS THAT COME
FROM THAT THIS IS WHERE ABC
UNDER AGE REPRESENTATIVES.
GO IN AND BUY LIQUOR.
BY DIFFERENT MEANS -- YOUR SENSE
OF OF HOW THOSE APPEALS ARE
BEING HANDLED AND THE EFFICACY
OF THAT PROGRAM IF YOU WOULD.
I I BELIEVE THE MINOR DUQUE
PROGRAM IS VERY EFFECTIVE --
IT'S THE ABC DEPARTMENT WORKS
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO ENSURE THAT
LICENSEES ARE SAYING DILIGENT.
AND RESPONSIBLE IN THEIR USE OF
OF THE LICENSE AND HOLDING THAT
PRIVILEGE -- SO CURRENTLY WHAT
WE SEE IS A VAST MAJORITY OF
MINORITY QUICK CASES WHERE --
MANY LICENSEES WILL APPEAL THE
FAIRNESS OF THAT BECAUSE IT
FEELS AT TIMES MAYBE LIKE A
STING OPERATION.
ON A ON A SMALL SCALE -- BUT WE
HAVE NEVER SEEN OR OF IT SINCE
I'VE SERVED ON THE BOARD I
HAVEN'T SEEN A REVERSAL IN THAT
REGARD SO I FEEL THAT IT'S
WORKING.
AND THE LICENSES ARE WHERE THE
THOUGHTS OF POTENTIAL.
OF HOLDING THAT HOLDING THAT-LICENSE THANK YOU AND THEN
RELATED TO THAT YOU ALSO
MENTIONED.
A PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE MAYBE NOT
DIRECTLY INVOLVED WITH AS A
MEMBER THE APPEALS BOARD BUT
EDUCATION A. B. C.'S DOING WITH
COLLEGE AGE STUDENTS I FOUND
THAT TO BE IMPORTANT AND TIMELY.
YES THANK YOU THERE IS A PROGRAM
THAT THE THE DEPARTMENT OF A. B.
C. AND THAT'S A SEPARATE
DEPARTMENT OBVIOUSLY AS YOU
STATED -- BUT I'M AWARE OF A
PROGRAM THAT THEY WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES.
BOTH YOU SEE IN STATE AND AGE
OTHER AGENCIES TO WORK ON
EDUCATION AND PREVENTION OF
BINGE DRINKING AND RAISING
AWARENESS AROUND EXCESSIVE
DRINKING ON STATE CAMPUSES.
I'M NOT SURE.
AGAIN HOW EFFECTIVE THE PROGRAMS
ARE BUT I KNOW THAT THEY'RE
MAKING EFFORTS IN THAT DIRECTION.
ENGINE FOR AGING FINAL QUESTION
BACK TO YOUR WORK ON THE BOARD I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S YOU'RE
SERVING WITH ONE OTHER MEMBER
RIGHT NOW IN THEIR SOME
VACANCIES.
HAS THAT POSED ANY PROBLEMS IN
TERMS OF SPLIT DECISIONS OR HOW
DO YOU GRAPPLE IF THERE IS A
DIVIDED DECISION.
THANK YOU -- WE HAVE A NEW BOARD
MEMBER AND NAME SUSAN BANANA AND
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO BE SERVING
WITH HER -- OUR FIRST BOARD
MEETING TOGETHER IS TOMORROW.
IN ONTARIO CALIFORNIA -- THE
RULES AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND IS
THAT.
IF WE WERE TO COME TO A SPLIT
DECISION THAT THE DECISION WOULD
REVERT BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
DECISION.
AND IT'S AT THE GOVERNOR'S
DISCRETION WHEN WE GET ANOTHER
BOARD MEMBER.
WELL THANK YOU AND AGAIN I'M AS
WE DISCUSS TO MISS BONNIE IS A
FORMER COLLEAGUE AS WELL SO
PLEASE CONVEY OUR HELLO THIS IS
YOU.
START SERVE WITH HER I WILL DO
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ADULATION SINKING.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER BATES.
THANK YOU ALL AND WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATIONS FOR A
REAPPOINTMENT THAT'S A REAL
SHOWDOWN FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE AND AND IN OUR
DISCUSSION IN MY OFFICE SINCE.
THAT YOU REALLY LIKE THE JOB AND
THAT YOU REALLY WELL PREPARED
AND DO A LOT OF THE HOMEWORK SO
THAT YOU ARE -- WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IF I MIGHT.
OF GO ON WITH SENATOR THE MONEY
HAD TO SAY ABOUT EDUCATION BUT
MINE FOCUSES ON I THINK OUR
DISCUSSION FOCUSED ON EDUCATION
FOR THE LICENSEES ESPECIALLY THE
SMALLER.
MOM AND POP TYPE BUSINESSES THAT
MIGHT MAKE MISTAKES THAT ARE
HONEST MISTAKES BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T KNOW -- AND WE TALKED TO
A IN DEPTH ABOUT THAT SO MY
QUESTION IS -- FOLLOWS UP FROM
OUR DISCUSSION FOCUSING ON
EDUCATION OF THE LICENSEES AND
HOW YOU MIGHT.
INCREASE AND EXPAND OUT WHERE
YOU SEE A TREND OF THE I DON'T
KNOW SIR I DIDN'T KNOW AND I WAS
THE REASON AND THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO NOT KNOW BECAUSE THEY
GOT THEIR LICENSE THEY SHOULD.
BUT I DO THINK THERE CAN BE A
GAP THERE AND WE SHOULD WE
DISCUSS THAT SO YOUR APPROACH TO
THEY ARE GOING FORWARD DO WE
HAVE A A PLAN WE MIGHT REQUIRE.
A LITTLE MORE EDUCATION BEFORE
THEY GET THE LICENSEWOULD THAT
BE SOMETHING THAT.
IS DOABLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ON THAT IS
THAT WOULD BE UNDER THE
DEPARTMENTS JURISDICTION
SPECIFICALLY HOWEVER I AM AWARE
THAT THEY HAVE A COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT.
ARE SEEM VERY ROBUST ONE IS THE
RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE SERVICE
PROGRAM AND THE OTHER IS CALLED
A LEAD PROGRAM FOR LICENSEES
THAT'S FREE AND VOLUNTARY SO I
DON'T THE NEW.
YOU KNOW THE HORIZONTAL VERSUS
VERTICAL OR THE RED STRIPES ON
THE CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WITH THAT IS
OUTSIDE OF OUR JURISDICTION TO
IMPLEMENT NEW EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS BUT IT CERTAINLY AS WE
SEE TRENDS AND AS WE SPOKE OF AS
WE START TO SEE TRENDS IN THE
APPEALS PROCESS.
THAT SOMETHING WE COULD
POTENTIALLY COLLABORATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND SAY HEY WE'RE
SEEING MORE OF THIS HOW ARE WE
HANDLING AND HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ALONG THOSE LINES.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY VERY
WORTHWHILE VERY VALUABLE AS WE
GO FORWARD.
OTHER ON AREA WE TOUCHED ON WAS
THE LENGTH OF THE APPEAL PROCESS
YES IN IMPROVING NOW BECAUSE BY
AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE RECEIVE A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS PEOPLE WAITING FOR A
DECISION -- AND WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO AB SHORTEN OUT.
YES ABSOLUTELY SO CURRENTLY THE
PROCESS DOES TAKE A LITTLE BIT
LONGER THAN WE WOULD LIKE -- THE
ONE BENEFIT TO THAT BEING THAT
THE LICENSEE.
DOES HAS A STAY OF THEIR
SUSPENSION OR REVOCATION AS IT
WERE WHILE IT'S IN THE P. A. B.
APPEALS PROCESS.
SO -- THEY'RE THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITH THEIR
FULLY OPERATIONAL.
MAINTAIN THEIR LICENSE -- DURING
THAT PROCESS HOWEVER THERE ARE
SOME AREAS OF A BOTTLE NECK THAT
I THINK THAT WE COULD IMPROVE
UPON AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TO DO A TRANSFER
OF DOCUMENTS AND I THINK IT HAS
TO DO WITH TECHNOLOGY AND
IMPROVING -- THAT TRANSFER BY
WAY OF DIGITIZING.
RECORDS FROM THE HEARINGS AND
TRANSCRIPTS OF THAT NATURE TO
SPEED UP THE PROCESS.
WE'RE HEARING A LOT ABOUT THAT
VARIOUS COMMITTEES REGARDING OUR
IT SYSTEMS HERE SO IT'S GOOD TO
HAVE THAT TOO MAYBE THE TO DO
LIST.
BOB THANK YOU AGAIN OF
CONGRATULATIONS I THINK YOU'RE
THEY HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB AND
GOING FORWARD I'M SURE THAT
YOU'RE GOING.
TO CONTINUE OPERATING THAT
FASHION SO I'LL BE PREPARED TO
SUPPORT TO WIN WE HAVE THE
MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ACTUALLY I
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AND
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU FOR TO
VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
CENTER ROTH I'M SURE -- AGAINST
CONGRATULATIONS I ABSOLUTELY
HAVE NO QUESTIONS STRUGGLING
WILL QUALIFY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MAKING THE MOTION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU ARE WONDERFUL LET ME
ASK THEN -- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW.
GREAT A SON THAT IS ACTUALLY.
WE HAVE HAD OTHER HEARINGS.
WELL IT CONGRATULATIONS AND
REMOTE AND IT IS GOOD TO SEE
THAT YOU REALLY DO I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES -- HIGHER ENJOY
THIS BECAUSE IT IS NOT A SIMPLE
THING IT'S A BALANCING ACT --
THAT'S NEVER REALLY EASY AND FOR
THOSE OF US HEAD OF SERVE
LOCALLY -- AND YET STILL HERE AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
HELLO THESE ISSUES PLAY OUT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS AND
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS -- IT
SENATOR ROTH ALWAYS INDICATES HE
WANTS TO MAKE THE MOTIONS SO I
SHALL LET HIM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK WILK AYE ATKINS HI.
CONGRATULATIONS YOU'VE BEEN A
WELL DOCTOR BREMEN I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE PLEASE ARE
COME ON UP.
THIS IS THE APPOINTMENT TO THE
CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS BOARD
WELCOME.
YOU.
WE WILL -- LET YOU MAKE.
ANY COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE OPENING INTRODUCE FOLKS AND
THEN WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO IT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WILL FIRST
OF ALL I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
WIFE FOR BEING HERE WITH ME
TODAY AND THE WONDERFUL STAFF AT
THE PANEL -- AND INCREASE IN
SERRA AND ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I THINK CHRISTINE MILES FOR
BEING VERY HELPFUL DURING THIS
PROCESS WONDERFUL IT WHY DON'T
YOU SHARE WITH US YOUR SPOUSE'S
NAME SERVICES -- TEACHER
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU GOVERNOR BROWN
GOVERNOR NEW SIM.
AND THEIR MINISTRATIONS OR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
SERVING THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A MEMBER OF THE
CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS PANEL
IS TRULY AN HONOR.
THE CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS
PANEL IS RESPONSIBLE FOR APPEALS
OF ANY DECISIONS.
BY STATE.
CANNABIS LICENSES FORTIES UNDER
PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR I WANT TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE ON THE PANEL BECAUSE I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THE NEW CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
SIMULTANEOUSLY I BELIEVE THAT MY
BACKGROUND AS A DIRECTOR AT THE
BROTHERHOOD CRUSADE SERVING
THOSE IMPACTED THE MOST BY THE
WAR ON DRUGS COUPLED WITH MY
EXPERIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THE PUBLIC POLICY AND EDUCATION
SECTORS.
MAKE ME UNIQUELY QUALIFIED FOR
THIS ROLE.
AS A MEMBER OF THE PANEL I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE GREAT
CHALLENGES AHEAD. FOR INSTANCE
I'M ACUTELY AWARE THAT.
THIS IS THE FIRST PANEL AND
THERE ARE GREAT UNKNOWNS. TO
MITIGATE CAPACITY IS AN ISSUE
I'M WORKING WITH THE C. CAPS
STAFF TO ENSURE WE ARE WELL
PREPARED FOR APPEALS.
AS A MEMBER OF THE PANEL IS MY
GOAL TO SERVE WITH INTEGRITY
ENSURING THAT ETHICS GUY MY
DECISIONS AND STAND AT THE
EPICENTER OF MY SERVICE.
I WILL ALWAYS BE FAIR AND JUST
IN MY DECISION MAKING.
ADDITIONALLY  WILL WORK
TIRELESSLY TO ENSURE THAT THE
PANEL OPERATES EFFECTIVELY.
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE
WILL NEED TO BE FINANCIALLY
PRUDENT TIMELY AND COMMUNICATIVE
TO ENSURE WE ARE AFFECTED LEE
SERVING OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
I WILL STRIVE TO ENSURE THERE
WAS A PANEL REMAIN NIMBLE AND
LEARN ALL THAT WE CAN.
IN THIS DYNAMIC ARENA -- IN
CLOSING ONCE MORE I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DID NOT THINK MY
BEAUTIFUL WIFE AND I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK MY PARENTS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS WHO ARE NOT HERE
WITH ME TODAY. FOR IS ON THIS
DAY -- SIXTEEN YEARS AGO THAT I
LOST MY FATHER WHO ALWAYS
INSTILLED IN ME THE IMPORTANCE
OF LIVING A LIFE OF SERVICE
PURPOSE AND LEADERSHIP.
TODAY AS I STAND BEFORE YOU I
HOPE YOU SPROUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATE ROTH
WHEN WE COME BACK OVER TO YOU --
MINIATURE A DOCTOR
CONGRATULATIONS I ACTUALLY HAVE --
NO QUESTION.
SEVEN LOOK FORWARD TO WATCHING
ISSUE MOVE FORWARD IN YOUR NEW
POSITION AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WILL.
BE DELIGHTED TO MOVE YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU MISTER
SENATOR HE SENATOR.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CONGRATULATIONS DR I ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY AND A LOT
OF STUFF WE TALKED ABOUT.
NOT UNDER YOUR PURVIEW BUT I
THINK WE HAVE THE SAME.
VISION TERMS OF WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO MOVE FORWARD TO TO TO TO
GROW THIS INDUSTRY.
BUT SOME OF YOU JUST MENTIONED --
OBSTRUCTING JUST CURIOUS --
ABOUT THAT COULD YOU TALK ABOUT
BUILDING OUR CAPACITY BECAUSE I
THINK SOME OF THE PROBLEMS WE
HAVE.
IN THIS INDUSTRIES IS WE AT
LEAST AT THE GOVERNMENT LEVEL
YOU HAVE WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROPER CAPACITY TO DO ALL THE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO.
SO CONSIDER YOU HAVEN'T HAD AN
APPELLATE YET AT THOUGH I THINK
YOUR EXPECT ONE'S PRICE SOMETIME
IN THE FALL -- DO YOU FEEL YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU GUYS HAVE.
THE THE PROPER CAPACITY OR DEAR
YOU NEED MORE RESOURCES OR I
DEFINITELY THINK WE ARE WELL
PREPARED FOR THE APPEALS PROCESS
AND I WILL GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND AND
TEAMS BEEN WORKING VERY HARD I
THINK WILL WORK WELL PREPARED
FOR THOSE APPEALS.
THEY FOR THAT ANSWER LOOKING I
LOOKING FOR DEAD BODY FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
SENATOR BATES YES.
WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION --
SO I WILL I WANT TO DO SURE WITH
THE WITH ALL OF US UP HERE YEAR
IDEA BECAUSE I THINK IT'S GREAT
HE SUGGESTED AN ANNUAL
EVALUATION OF THE PANEL TO ALLOW
MEMBERS TO DISCUSS HOW WELL.
ARE YOU ARE PERFORMING AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
AS LEGISLATORS LOOK FOR IN OUR
ON OUR COMMISSIONS AND
COMMITTEES TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDED THE RESOURCES AND THAT
YOU ARE GIVING US FEEDBACK OF
THINGS NEED TO BE CHANGED SO. TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS ON THEM A
DOCTOR REMAIN BECAUSE I THINK
THAT YOU REALLY CAN'T IT ON HE
DID OUT OF THE PARK AS WE SAVE
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY AS A NEW
MEMBER.
SEE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MEASURE OURSELVES DEFINITELY
THANK YOU -- ONE I THINK THAT
DATA IS EXTREMELY.
IMPORTANT AS WE ARE NEW PANEL --
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL AND SO I THINK THAT
LOOKING AT OUR SUCCESS IN TERMS
OF OUR TIMELINESS IN TERMS OF
APPEALS -- HOW WILL WE SERVED
OUR STAKEHOLDERS -- EXETER AT
THE AND OF OF EACH FISCAL YEAR --
WILL BE GREAT AND ALLOW US TO
FORM AN FORM RATHER OUR FUTURE
DECISIONS FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
THANK YOU AND I KNOW YOU BRING
THAT FORWARD FROM YOUR WORK IN
SOCIAL WORK.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHARED SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOU ARE WHEN WE'RE
FINISHED HERE AND WISH YOU THE
VERY BEST I THINK IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU AND YOU'LL
BRING SOMETHING TO THE PANEL.
THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAT
WE HAVE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
AND LEGAL AN ATTORNEY RINGING
THE PEOPLE AND THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU WILL TOUCH AND HELP AND
UNFORTUNATELY A SLAM.
YOU HAVE TO SAY NO TO HOP SO
THOSE ARE CHALLENGES THAT I
THINK YOU'RE WELL EQUIPPED TO
MEET SO.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU TOO THANK YOU.
GREAT SKILL TO HAVE IN IN A LOT
OF WORK SENATOR.
CENTER MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND DOCTOR
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND BEING
A PIONEERING MEMBER OF OF THIS.
NEW BOARD -- I WAS IMPRESSED
WITH THE THE BREADTH OF YOUR
EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND SOCIAL
WORK BACKGROUND -- AS WE
DISCUSSED.
YOU'RE GONNA BE HEARING APPEALS
FROM DIFFERENT AGENCIES
DIFFERENT ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
FOOD NAG.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH YOUR
OF CANNABIS CONTROL ON THE
DISPENSARIES.
SINCE IT'S KIND OF A LOW TIME
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF ACTUAL.
APPEALS BOARD WORK MAYBE JUST
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE WHAT
YOU'RE.
DOING TO CONVERSE YOURSELF IN
THESE DIFFERENT ENFORCEMENT
AREAS IN THE TYPES OF APPEALS
THAT MIGHT BE COMING TO YOU.
THANK YOU -- MOST DEFINITELY WE
HAVE RECEIVED -- PRESENTATIONS
FROM EACH ENTITY -- AND OUR
START UP PHASE AS A PANEL SO
THAT WE CAN JUST UNDERSTAND THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE -- FROM WHICH
THESE LICENSING ENTITIES WORK --
AND THEN SIMULTANEOUSLY -- I'VE
BEEN DIVING INTO THE REGULATIONS
OF EACH ENTITY BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THAT SERVES AS THE
GROUNDWORK IN THE CONTEXT --
THAT'S GOING TO INFORM OUR
DECISIONS -- AND THEN.
FINALLY AS IT RELATES -- TO THE
ENTITIES -- WE RECEIVE A A BODY
OF RESEARCH ON WHICH THE
ACADEMIC IN ME LOVES THIS WEEKLY --
AROUND -- PUBLICATIONS IN AREAS
OF EQUITY AND AREAS OF LICENSING
FEDERALIZATION -- YOU NAME IT --
BUT EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN LEARN --
RESEARCH WISE HERE -- ON THE
LOCAL IN THE LOCAL LEVELS FOR
MYSELF AND LOS ANGELES TO STAY
LEVEL AND FEDERAL LEVELS.
I DO THAT WEEKLY SO I'M I'M
SPENDING AN AMPLE AMOUNT OF TIME
RESEARCHING SO THAT I I'M WELL
PREPARED -- FOR MY ROLE.
THANK YOU AND THAT WAS CERTAINLY
THE CONCLUSION I REACHED -- TO
THE EXTENT IT'S APPROPRIATE I'D
SUGGESTED AS AS THINGS TAKE
SHAPE IS IF YOU BECOME AWARE IN
YOUR WORK OF THINGS THAT SHOULD
BE BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION WE'D
CERTAINLY.
APPRECIATE THAT AS WE TRY.
TO GET IT RIGHT THERE'S A HUGE
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE HERE THAN
MANY OF US ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
IN ADDITION TO THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ENTREPRENEURS AND IN OTHERS
SO -- AGAIN I WANT TO OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS AND I THINK YOUR
FATHER'S VERY PROUD OF YOU TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
LET ME -- MOVED TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE NOMINATION TODAY
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
AGAIN I SAY -- WE'VE HAD WE'VE
HAD QUITE.
LENGTHY HEARINGS IN THE PAST SO
THIS IS A TRIBUTE TO OBVIOUSLY --
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE SUPPORT.
THE NOMINATION SENATOR ROTH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- MADAM SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROSS ROSS I WILL.
WILK AYE ATKINS HI [inaudible]
UNANIMOUS CONGRATULATIONS.
WELL THANK YOU COLLEAGUES -- WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO EXECUTIVE
SESSION -- AS SOON AS THOSE
PRESENT EXIT SO WE'LL JUST TAKE
A MINUTE OR